so do you like fishing
um if you've ever been deep sea fishing
before there is a there is a there's a
you can fish and then when the fish gets
oh my God I can't do this business
anymore
[Music]
all right so what were you just saying
right now uh Nick we said it's funny to
call our wives [__] sometimes no no
it's like wives in general like
anybody's wild I got it I disagree it's
a dude it's only funny when you love
them yeah it's totally funny if it's a
parody of how you really feel tip goes
she goes hey uh do you ever call me a
[__] behind my back and I'm like babe
nah
you got a good laugh about it you ever
call it to her face I think that's the
funniest thing in the world nah uh
I don't know I gotta try I'll try
tonight ask her when somebody's doing
something we're just doing something
that's pissing you off uh stop being a
[__] stop that hey can you stop in a
[__] please
make some hot yeah it actually breaks
the moment and then we both start
laughing yeah and it actually takes it
down two notches and we could actually
talk about the problem
I don't know if that's gonna work for
everybody someone didn't put the paper
towel over the food when they put in the
microwave you know who did that okay
I would get a divorce speaking of um
somebody explained to me what's
happening in this photo speaking of
[__] wives That's the oh that's the
Chinese Lotto winner the publishing Club
I thought that was a Chinese Scantron I
thought that was it's one of those a lot
of things where you want to hide your
identity so you show up in a costume
right exactly oh that's tight so this is
the Lotto winner
the other guy's presenting it yeah the
other guy's presenting the chat [__] all
right and the guy who won the lotto is
in costume that's smart what if they
what if they trace this guy and they go
this guy's giving out money let's get
him
so so why would he hide his identity
because you don't get scammed bro
because his family's gonna come [__]
ask him for money and [__] dude yeah
because he specifically wanted to keep a
secret from his wife and his child over
fear yeah because she's being a little
[__] all the time over fears it would
make them lazy oh that's the most that's
so Chinese yeah
and he's right dude he's probably right
so this was a he's gonna make him lazy
this is a man from Southern China who
decided to keep his 30 million dollar
lottery ticket the secret damn to his
wife that's correct and his kid yeah
how'd that works that's wild how's it
worked perfectly man that's the same
type of like thought process like oh you
got to sleep with your socks on You're
Gonna Catch cold
yeah
that's exactly the same
my wife she can be so lazy
that's so funny there's such cause and
effect like giant leaps yeah don't go to
sleep with your hair when you could get
cancer yeah yeah it's like [__] really
for so long in my life I believe that
you know what I mean like I would never
do that there's no such thing as a
slippery slope over there yeah it just
goes zero to 100 on everything yeah
Superman the ride every time you're
gonna die tomorrow yeah I I think that'd
be pretty cool to keep it if you could
win the lotto keep a secret and then
your wife for the rest of your life just
like how are we affording all this [__]
yeah don't worry about it the laziness
is coming out and then she finds the
costume in the closet would you use that
for don't worry about it honey if she's
still working at the matcha spot for 30
years
oh [__] she's working at jumpy it's a
family business it is maintain the cover
no you can't quit were you telling us
about someone you knew in the car scene
yeah that had a Lambo and then like uh
what was like everyone like people asked
him what are you doing because I work at
Ralph's or whatever he kept saying he
was he bagged groceries and everyone
would just laugh and he actually did but
that was his real job he didn't quit
yeah that's super that won the lotto
that's actually the best way to not lose
it yeah maintain what you're doing and
then just keep that as like a big
savings hell yeah you're chilling dude
and then everyone thought he was being
sarcastic for years like I saw that guy
for years and we would just go haha
that's funny man oh here comes the
grocery bagger and like he really was
and then we found out because he was so
socially awkward we were like is that
really a grocery bagger and then someone
was like yeah dude he won the lotto he
just works at I don't know Gelson's or
something
I saw this doc about
um these uh uh lunch ladies they're like
School Lunch Ladies
and um they won the lotto because you
know they would pull as a as a group oh
and then they would they would they
would be like hey let's let's as a as a
fun thing let's all like pull money and
they all became [__] millionaires but
they all kept the job last time nope and
smart this is a Hot Topic right now
because the lotto in California is what
like 1.3 billion that just uh the
Powerball just got won uh I think
somebody just won yeah it was 1.4
billion like last night or something
like that what an [__] so out of all
the things we do for work let's say we
won the lotto what would you stop doing
this show
JK dancing for work maybe no you haven't
even peaked yet shut the [__] up why
would you stop now bro dancing for fun
is different from dancing for work you
are you saying this ain't fun bro
you're mad at me about the Wisconsin
video I would love to do this for money
I think I would still do the same [__] I
would do everything just less on the uh
volume aspect but then production wise
would be crazy Crank It Up oh yeah oh
that's true I would put more money in JK
and just do crazy [__] like we're gonna
do JK news like in the San Diego Zoo but
instead of like on the train like in the
lion so far okay we need Joe to win the
lotto yeah we're trying to Target Dodge
Lions yeah [__] like that so we do that
but then we only need to do like five
videos or ten videos versus like uh 20
in a day you know yeah I see it cool
slow down production that's what I'm
saying bring the volume down but then
the production is quality right yeah we
need to win the lotto something like
that so in this situation right he said
I didn't tell my wife and child for fear
that they would be too complacent and
would not work or work hard in the
future her he has bought 40 tickets in
eastern uh wherever the [__] you
pronounce this and each ticket had the
same seven numbers on it 2 15 19 26 27
29 and two again after realizing he won
he placed himself in a hotel room for
the night before claiming his prize to
avoid misplacing his ticket oh that said
great did not leave the hotel because I
was afraid to go out and lose the
lottery ticket the freshly minted
millionaire uh said he'd been betting on
the lottery for over a decade but has
only won minor prizes in the past so he
considers buying the lotto a hobby for
him his family doesn't care about it he
says he doesn't spend much money on it
but it provides a ray of Hope for
himself
and the crazy thing that sounds sad
that does sound classy it sounded pretty
sad it's a way of Hope in my darkness
similarly though on uh he [__] hates
his family life and his life sucks
that's why he's keeping a secret yeah uh
but a woman on Reddit like responded to
this news article that also got posted
and said that she revealed that she kept
her lottery win a secret from her
husband for several years as well what
at that time they weren't married
so she was legally still uh single and
she said it wasn't a lot of money but it
was enough to change her life the AKA
like after taxes is still like 480 000
or something like that that's a lot man
but still choosing to like you know
because she was technically single uh by
she could still say that you know she
could still take the winnings
anonymously yeah so she decided to keep
it between just her and like the
government and Taxation and stuff she
didn't tell her friends her family or
anything like that because of just that
same anxiety and fear that it would like
upend and and change the way that her
relationships would be or the way people
perceived her and also just it changes
people I was listening to Derek Lewis
was a UFC fighter and he grew up in the
hood and he was on Joe Rogan and he was
talking about how like you know the
minute he became champ for all these
family members are like this right like
what are you gonna do for me and then he
was like all right because they uh Joe
asked him like are you ever gonna hook
it for family he goes [__] no and he
goes how come he goes because a lot a
bunch of my family members that I bought
cars homes for they end up selling just
to buy drugs and stuff damn oh it's like
you money doesn't fix the problem it
feels like it does because it always
feels like exactly it creates more
problems yeah that's why I don't know if
I'm weird but um I want to see that the
the answer short answer is yes expose
which members are garbage [__] yeah dude
I [__] dangle bait all over that
[__] and be like come take it
[__] so I can tell you no what would be
your bait and who are the immediate
family members you're considering oh I
filtered them all throughout life my
family's [__] sick like I could I
could have a million dollars right now
and nobody would say give this to me
they wouldn't nobody would say that no
the only person is probably my stepdad
that goes I got a great investment for
you and he's been pitching [__]
business Investments for me for so long
dude it was so funny when we had a
barbecue out in Hawaii like Dave I was
like David watch out my stepdad will
talk like a [__] you gotta tell
them shut up and he speaks English too
like oh his English yeah I mean he used
to work for uh the the the the the the
the federal government like in
Washington DC yeah so like he has an
accent still but he talks like a turtle
because he's old and he speaks like this
so he takes a long time to make a
sentence and you don't know that he's
pitching to you so he'll right now his
whole thing is like um
he has friends who developed this Tech
that already exists was pitching in his
voice so do you like fishing
um if you ever been deep sea fishing
before there is a there is a there was a
you can fish and then when the fish gets
oh my God I can't do this business
anymore it shocks the fish it shocks the
fish and then you can reel it in so so
it's imagine this on Shark Tank and in
the whole time you think he's just
telling you a story then he goes so what
do you think what do you mean you win
it's a good business right
[Laughter]
so he's always trying to pitch me [__]
like watch Dude somebody's gonna make
this and multi-million dollar business
[__] changes the entire fishing
atmosphere dude he made friends with
organized crime in the Philippines he's
he's so naive he doesn't [__] know
this he doesn't know right but when he
was explaining to to me the story
he's basically trying to sell illegally
caught fish
because you know there's like you have
to have like you got you gotta fish in
like areas that are legal and you can't
you know you can't go out and get tuna
wherever you want in in commercially
right so he goes he was telling me and
he was explaining to me yeah I could get
a really good deal on tuna and this and
that and I'm all like what and I was
like listening to it I'm like dude this
sounds like you're getting illegal tuna
you can get him [__] real you get a
big ass trouble for doing this and then
he goes I don't think so these guys are
tied to the government and I'm like
they're paying the government off that's
why and then he shows me this party like
they're all like hanging out and I'm
like they don't look like chilled dudes
they all got guns and [__] everyone has
[__] gold chains
you so [__] naive dude but it's I
mean like dude he's like
86. he's 87 he's still trying to like do
[__] right and um his latest thing and
this was actually cool he he created a
non-profit organization helping Filipino
nurses come to Japan and and um the
issue was they weren't so Japan has this
aging population and they basically need
more uh medical staff and there's a ton
in the Philippines but the problem is
it's really hard for people to learn how
to read and write Japanese so he created
a program where they come and they learn
how to read and write so they could pass
the nursing test and stuff like that and
so he's always doing [__] like that but
all of his ideas are so stupid except
for that one and then he's always trying
to pitch to me and saying I think it's a
great investment that's his last every
single time I think it's a great
investment you'll do really well and I'm
like I'm not paying 300 000 for some
[__] fishing thing that shocks fish
I like that he has like the nurse like
Headhunter and then fish shocker than
like the same Notepad
[Music]
thank you